this is rockwool
and it's the external wall insulation
that we're going to put all the way
around the house eleanor watts is so
worried about the rising cost of energy
she is extensively retrofitting her
1930s three bed home triple glazing
insulation investing now to save on her
bills
fuel prices are going through the roof
and i can't afford 5 000 pounds a year
on my fuel bills but because i've got my
pension pot i'm lucky enough to have 50
000 pounds now
i'm spending the whole lot
on making my house more energy efficient
but as the cost of living crisis worsens
a growing number of people will struggle
to afford even a fraction of that
upfront some trapping them in homes that
leak heat
the citizens advice bureau is worried
the costs are just so incredibly high
and people can't afford them but we
really believe that you know it can be
done it just needs government support
and you know even more than it can be
done it has to be done doesn't it we
cannot be in this situation again next
winter and energy efficiency is the best
way to stop that
and there's much more at stake here than
just the cost of living
there are 29 million homes in the uk and
they are responsible for nearly a fifth
of this country's carbon emissions
so if we can't decarbonize them move
them from gas to electricity for heating
and cooking and hot water then we simply
will not hit our climate change targets
the government says the answer is
switching to efficient electric heat
pumps but there's a price problem here
too right now they cost an average of
ten thousand pounds to buy and install
these two houses real houses that's why
greg jackson who runs the renewable
energy company octopus is using his
research and development center to try
and bring those costs down and quickly
with previous fossil fuel crises we
didn't have any alternatives
but now we do
there isn't a magic money tree
but
if we don't invest in the future
this is going to happen again and again
and again
there are some government schemes to
help but it won't be enough for everyone
who needs it leaving too many stuck with
high bills unable to afford the cost of
going green at home and potentially
threatening a flagship policy to limit
global warming
hannah thomas peter sky news